>> WE ARE BACK LIKE WE NEVER
LEFT.
WE WERE HERE LAST WEEK, YOU
KNOW WHAT WE DID LAST WEEK.
WE CAME UP WITH A PARLAY THAT
ACTUALLY HIT. SO WE ARE BACK
AGAIN.
WHAT UP, EVERYBODY?
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN, THE MAN
THAT COLLECTS US TO YOU GUYS,
PRODUCER RYAN.
>> FEELING GOOD.
PRETTY EXCITING DAY, THE BOOKS
ARE VULNERABLE TONIGHT SO MAYBE
WE WILL TAKE SOME MORE MONEY.
LET'S GO.
>> LET'S TAKE MORE MONEY.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, PRODUCER
RYAN?
>> WE ARE GOING TO HIT TWO
PARLAYS IN A ROW.
WE ARE SO HOT RIGHT NOW.
>> RYAN IS READY. I'M READY.
LAST WEEK, WE BUILT OUR FIVE
WAY PARLAY AND IT HIT.
WE HAVE TO RUN IT BACK.
DROP YOUR BEST BETS IN THE CHAT
, WE WILL PUT THEM INTO A
PARLAY.
RYAN, WHAT IS IT LIKE TONIGHT?
>> MATT WHO JUMPED IN HERE
BEFORE WE STARTED AND SAID HE
CASHED USA AND IRAN CORRECT
SCORE, HE SAID HOPING WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY PULL OFF SOME HEAT
TONIGHT.
I AM BIG ON DALLAS.
HUGE ON CLAY OVER 17.5.
WE ALREADY GOT SOME PLAYS.
>> ALREADY GOT SOME PLAYS IN THE
CHAT.
>> I LIKE IT.
HE HAS BEEN BAWLING.
>> FOR THE PEOPLE THAT MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN HERE LAST WEEK OR
BEFORE, GREG IS THE BIGGEST
WARRIORS FAN I KNOW.
ANY WARRIORS FAN WILL GO ON
THAT SIDE.
>> HE HAS JUST BEEN BAWLING.
I'LL GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS IF
YOU WANT.
I WILL GIVE YOU SOME KLAY
THOMPSON NUMBERS.
YOU ARE SURFING WHILE I GIVE
HIM THESE KLAY THOMPSON NUMBERS.
HE WENT FOR 21, BEFORE THAT 18,
BEFORE THAT HE WENT FOR 21,
BEFORE THAT HE WENT FOR 20,
THEN 19. I CAN KEEP GOING.
THERE'S A REASON WHY I LIKE HIM.
IT'S THE REASON WHY I LIKE HIM.
>> MATT, IT'S HIS FIRST TIME IN
THE STREAM.
SHOULD WE PLUG IT IN?
>> WE HAVE SOME OTHER PLAYS IN
HERE BUT I WILL READ THOSE. I
THINK WE CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY WE
ALL LIKE HIM OVER 17.5 POINTS.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> SHALL WE KEEP GOING?
>> I'M SEEING A LOT OF REGGIE
BULLOCK.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING?
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO WIN.
SOMEBODY SAID LUCA 4+3.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> HE HAS DONE IT BEFORE BUT IF
WE ARE TRYING TO WIN AND BE
CONFIDENT IN THIS, THAT'S TOO
MANY.
THAT IS JUST MY THOUGHT.
>> I SEE AN INTERESTING ONE.
OVER 3.5 ASSISTS.
JORDAN PULL OVER 3.5 ASSISTS.
WE KNOW HE RUNS THAT SECOND
LINEUP FOR THE WARRIORS.
>> I ONLY WORRY THAT THAT
SECOND UNIT, IF THEY ARE TRYING
TO PLAY FROM BEHIND, IT COULD
BE IFFY.
MAYBE HOLD ONTO THAT ONE.
>> LET ME LIST SOME OF HIS
NUMBERS.
HE RUNS THE SECOND UNIT, HE IS
THE POINT GUARD IN THAT SECOND
UNIT . ALTHOUGH HE SCORES, I
THINK HE AVERAGES 16.
HE IS THE FACILITATOR IN THAT
LINEUP.
LAST TIME, SIX ASSISTS.
BEFORE THAT, FIVE.
BEFORE THAT, FOUR.
FOUR, EIGHT.
HE IS GOING TO PASS THE BALL.
>> MAY I INTERRUPT FOR A SECOND?
>> GO AHEAD.
>> WE HAVE OTHER PLAYS WE CAN
GET TO.
THOMAS HAS BEEN RELENTLESSLY
DROPPING CURRY OVER 6.5 ASSISTS.
WE HAVE ARTIE TAKEN THE -115.
WE COULD TAKE LUCA 30+ POINTS,
OR CURRY 6+ ASSISTS.
>> JORDAN POOL OVER 3.5
ASSISTS.
>> I'M WITH GREG.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE STOPPED
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
WE WENT THROUGH THE NUMBERS.
THE NUMBERS MAKE SENSE, THE
AUDIENCE VOTED FOR IT.
PLUG IT IN.
>> I'M GOING TO AGREE, SIMPLY
BECAUSE THAT SECOND UNIT IS
SUCH A SPARK PLUG FOR THE
WARRIORS THAT HE DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE TO DO MUCH, JUST PASSING
THE BALL TO THE CORNER.
I THINK THIS WILL BE A REALLY
CLOSE GAME, SO I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE WILL BE THAT BIG OF
LEADS.
HE'S IN A POSITION TO GET THREE
TO FIVE, ALL WE NEED IS FOUR.
I LIKE IT.
>> THIS IS FOR PRODUCER MAX.
I SEE OVER, THE CHAT WANTS IT.
ASSISTS OVER 3.5.
I AM WITH GREG 100%. HOW MUCH
MORE DO WE NEED?
>> LOCK IT IN.
>> YOU GUYS ARE GOING TO KILL
ME WITH THESE.
>> IF WE TAKE +100, I DON'T
HATE IT BUT WE ARE TRYING TO
WIN.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD BE THE
ONE TO TALK US DOWN.
BUT HERE WE GO.
>> I SEE AN INTERESTING ONE.
OVER 7.5 POINTS.
>> NOW YOU'RE TALKING.
>> HE'S BEEN SCORING AT A
DECENT CLIP.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A LOW NUMBER TO
ME.
THAT TEAM HAS BEEN PLAYING WAY
ABOVE.
>> WE CAN'T GO ANY LOWER THAN
THAT.
>> WHAT ELSE TO BE GOT?
>> MARK PERKINS.
HIT US WITH THE NUMBERS.
>> I'M DONE.
I AM NOT SAYING ANYTHING ELSE
FOR THIS PARLAY.
SINCE YOU GUYS DON'T WANT TO
FOLLOW THE PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE
ARE GIVING THESE PICS.
>> I SEE ONE, IT'S HIS
BIRTHDAY, JULIUS RANDALL.
>> I LOVE THAT NARRATIVE.
I AM SO IN ON THIS.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE NUMBER IS.
>> I LIKE THAT.
THE TRUTH ABOUT IT, WE NEED TO
TAKE IT EASY ON THESE NEXT TWO
LEGS.
WE ARE ALREADY UP TO +524.
I SAID I WAS DONE, BUT I CAN'T
BE DONE.
BUT THE COMMENTERS, ANDREW
WIGGINS 15+ POINTS.
THEY SAID THAT.
>> ALSO SAID STEPH CURRY UNDER
30 POINTS.
HOW DO WE FEEL ABOUT THAT?
HE LIKES THE JOSH HART PICK.
WE WEREN'T ABLE TO PICK IT IN
BECAUSE IT WAS OVER 7.5 POINTS.
THE ORIGINAL NUMBER IS 10.5.
LET'S GO BACK.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
NOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT FOR
SURE.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT IT DOES.
NOW IT WILL GIVE US A CHANCE TO
GET CRAZY IF WE WANT TO.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GO
BACK AS WE ARE LOOKING FOR MORE
PLAYS.
WE DEFINITELY GOT. HE WAS LIKE
THIS WAS THE GOOSE EGG PLAY OF
THE YEAR.
TOO BAD WE DON'T HAVE HIM ON
THE SLEET -- SLATE.
>> WE GOT ENOUGH JUICE NOW.
KING J SAYS OVER 1.5.
>> HAS BEEN EVERYTHING THAT
THEY WANTED.
>> I DON'T HATE THAT AT ALL.
>> WE HAVE DONE ENOUGH OF THE
LEG WORK.
>> PUT WHAT YOU DON'T LIKE
ABOUT THE PARLAY.
>> WE STARTED OUT KLAY THOMPSON
, OVER 17 POINT FIVE POINTS.
HE DROPPED THAT PIC.
THIRD LEG, JULIUS RANDALL ON
HIS BIRTHDAY TO SCORE AT LEAST
20 POINTS.
TERRENCE MANN, 10+ POINTS FOR
THE CLIPPERS AND LAST LEG,
BRUNSON JUST ONE.
JUST 13.
>> I AM SEEING A LOT OF
POSITIVE VIBES IN THE CHAT.
FIVE THUMBS UP.
EVERYBODY LOVES IT.
>> THAT IS ONLY ONE.
NOW WE ARE GETTING THE
FEEDBACK.
THUMBS DOWN.
I'M WILLING TO MOVE A LITTLE
BIT.
>> I DO LIKE THAT THE CHAT IS
GIVING US IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK.
THAT IS THE ONLY THAT IS REALLY
IN QUESTION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING THUMBS UP
. A FEW THUMBS DOWN BUT I SEE
MORE THUMBS UP.
>> IT MIGHT BRING US DOWN A
LITTLE BIT.
LET'S SWAP THAT ONE AND SEE
WHAT IT DOES.
STILL 7 TO 1. THAT IS A VACUUM
DOWN THERE.
I THINK THIS IS A BETTER PLAY.
I REALLY LIKE THIS.
I DON'T SEE HOW THIS DOESN'T
HIT.
>> SOMEBODY SAID HE'S SHAKY.
NO BAD VIBES, GOOD VIBES ONLY.
>> I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
WE ARE GOING TO ROCK WITH IT.
THUMBS UP IF YOU ARE ROCKING
WITH IT, THUMBS DOWN IF YOU'RE
NOT.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS WHAT WE ARE
GOING TO ROCK WITH . I WILL
JUST GIVE THE PEOPLE MORE TIME.
>> JULIUS RANDALL, JAELYN
BRUNSON 1+3, FOR OUR LAST LEG
8+.
>> I LOVE IT.
WE ARE GETTING GOOD FEEDBACK.
I SEE A COUPLE THUMBS UP,
PEOPLE SAYING YOU GUYS SWAPPED,
THAT WAS GENIUS.
>> I'VE BEEN HEARING THAT.
THIS IS A LOCK.
WE ARE LOCKING IT IN.
WHAT ARE WE MOST NERVOUS ABOUT?
>> I THINK PERSONALLY, I AM NOT
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT ANY OF
THEM.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I WOULD BE
WORRIED.
>> THE ONLY THING I'M WORRIED
ABOUT IS JULIUS RANDALL.
PUTTING MONEY ON THE NEW YORK
KNICKS.
>> IT'S HIS BIRTHDAY.
I'M GETTING FEEDBACK, WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON WHAT I'M
GETTING FEEDBACK ABOUT JORDAN
POOLE.
>> GOOD OR BAD?
>> BAD.
THEY ARE SAYING THEY WANT TO
SWITCH.
>> WHAT PLAY?
>> WHAT IF WE DID 15 FOR HIM?
>> IT WAS PLUS MONEY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
>> I DO THINK HE WILL HAVE A
GREAT GAME.
WHAT WERE WE TALKING ABOUT?
WHEN YOU TAKE THE TEST IN
COLLEGE, YOU GO WITH YOUR GUT.
WE WENT WITH OUR GUT, IF YOU
ARE TELLING US NOW THAT THE
FULL PLAY IS NOT A LOCK, YOU'RE
TOO LATE.
>> WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
WE WOULD LOVE TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE.
>> LET'S GO OVER THAT ONE MORE
FINAL TIME BEFORE WE MOVE ON.
>> WE HAVE LOCKED IN.
KLAY THOMPSON OVER 17.5, JORDAN
POOLE OVER  3.5 ASSISTS, JULIUS
RANDALL, BRUNSON AND 8+
REBOUNDS.
>> LOVE IT.
>> I BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO WIN.
WE ARE SEVEN WEEKS INTO THE NBA
SEASON, SO LET'S TALK FUTURES,
LET US KNOW WHO YOUR FAVORITE
FUTURE BUT IS.
I DID NOT DO THIS BECAUSE I AM
TALKING TO MR. WARRIORS.
THE WARRIORS STARTED SLOW, THEY
ARE PLAYING BETTER.
I LIKE WHAT HE'S DOING. 10 TO 1
FEELS LIKE REALLY GOOD VALUE
BECAUSE THE TWO GUYS IN FRONT
OF HIM ARE PLAYING OUT OF THEIR
MINDS RIGHT NOW.
IF THEY REGRESS, HE'S GOING TO
MOVE UP.
WHAT WE LOVE TO CALL CLOSING
LINE VALUE.
IT FEELS LIKE A GOOD NUMBER FOR
STAFF.
>> ROCKING WITH STEPH CURRY TO
WIN MVP.
THE THING ABOUT I HOPE HE DOES
HE ALWAYS STARTS OFF HOT, THEN
THOSE LEGS CATCH UP TO HIM.
PLAYING WITH INJURIES AND THEN
THEY GO TO WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
MVP, MAYBE.
I DO LIKE IT.
BUT MAYBE.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
THE CHAT.
DO YOU SEE ANY INTERESTING FROM
THEM?
>> I SEE SAYING THE CELTICS GO
BACK TO THE FINALS. I
AGREE.
NO BIAS INVOLVED.
>> DID YOU JUST HAVE A STROKE?
>> THEY ARE GOING BACK.
THEY MAY NEVER LOSE ANOTHER
GAME.
DISAGREEING WITH YOU A LITTLE
BIT, SAYING LUCA MVP.
LUCA MVP HAS BEEN A POPULAR TAKE
FOR A FEW WEEKS.
HE'S CLEARLY ON ANOTHER LEVEL
FROM EVERYBODY BUT YOU THINK
THAT THE NBA MIGHT GIVE IT TO
SOMEBODY ELSE? VOTER FATIGUE IS
WHAT THEY CALL IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T THINK
SO.
THAT MIGHT HAPPEN.
>> LeBRON COULD WIN MVP EVERY
YEAR.
LET IT BE OBJECTIVE.
ONE OF THE OBJECTIVE COMMENTS I
SEE IS ALEXANDER SHOULD BE MVP
DISCUSSION.
THAT IS VERY INTERESTING.
>> DEFINITELY ON THE MOST
IMPROVED RADAR.
HE IS AFTER AVERAGING 30. IN
TERMS OF MOST VALUABLE PLAYER.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT, THEY
DON'T EVEN WIN A GAME.
>> HE IS 55 TO 1 TO WIN MVP.
WHO KNOWS?
>> YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET ME
TO SAY ANYTHING POSITIVE ABOUT
PHILADELPHIA.
>> HE HAS BEEN BALLING, BUT
THE SAME THING WITH STEPH CURRY.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO PLAY DURABILITY
IT'S A GREAT BET, HE IS A FREAK
ATHLETE. HE MIGHT BE THERE.
THE ODDS ARE THAT HE MIGHT BE
THERE AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
SO I DON'T KNOW. I'VE NEVER SEEN
NOBODY FALL ON THE GROUND MORE
THAN JOEL EMBIID.
FALLS ON THE GROUND FOR NO
REASON.
>> IF THEY CAN GET BACK UP TO
THE TOP OF THE EAST, HE SHOULD
BE IN THE DISCUSSION.
>> HE DOES GET INJURED A LOT.
AND HE IS 12 TO 1, WHEN HE IS
ON THE COURT HE IS PLAYING
INCREDIBLE.
BUT 12 TO 1 ODDS, YOU HAVE TO
FACTOR IN.
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR AND JASON
TATUM MVP.
>> I THINK I EXPECTED A LITTLE
MORE TO START.
BUT MAYBE THAT'S BECAUSE HE WAS
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE BIG TEN
LAST YEAR.
HE IS JUST A FREAK ATHLETE.
GREAT TALENT, CAN MAKE SHOTS
AND FACILITATE BUT IT'S GOING
TO BE HARD TO WIN ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR WHEN YOUR TEAM IS 5-17.
YOU JUST HAVE TO PLAY A LITTLE
BETTER.
IF THE PISTONS CAN FIND THEIR
STRIDE, I LIKE IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAD HIGHER
HOPES AND THAT HAS SHIFTED
BECAUSE THEY STARTED REALLY
SLOW.
>> I LIKE THE OTHER PICS,
JAYSON TATUM.
WE JUST TALKED ABOUT DURABILITY.
HE'S ONE OF THOSE GUYS THAT
COULD BE WITH THE CELTICS
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON.
SPRINKLE, I LIKE IT.
I LIKE THE JAYSON TATUM THING.
>> JAYSON TATUM IS +350.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M TAKING THAT.
DEVIN BOOKER MVP.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT PLAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE.
>> I'M NOT EVEN GOING TO WASTE
A LOT OF TIME ON THAT ONE.
THAT'S A DONATION.
LET'S GET TWO MORE AND GET THIS
THING GOING.
>> JUMPING IN HERE SAYING I
NEED MONEY NOW.
I FEEL YOU.
FUTURES IS LIKE THE STOCK
MARKET, YOU HAVE TO INVEST.
>> I FEEL THAT.
IT IS LIKE THE STOCK MARKET.
IF YOU PLAY A GOOD FUTURE EARLY,
YOU WILL REAP THE BENEFITS WHEN
YOU WIN.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THAT.
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THAT
INVESTMENT PART.
I'M TRYING TO WIN TODAY, I'M
TRYING TO WIN NOW.
>> IT IS ALSO JUST A GOOD WAY,
IT GIVES YOU A REASON TO ROOT
FOR ANOTHER TEAM.
HALLIBURTON MOST IMPROVED.
>> ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT THE POINT GUARD IS IN
THIS LEAGUE, EVEN THOUGH THE
PACERS AREN'T ONE OF THOSE
BETTER TEAMS, 40 ASSISTS AND NO
TURNOVERS. THAT IS ABSURD.
YOU COULD GET A TURNOVER FOR
DRIBBLING OFF YOUR LEG.
HE HASN'T TURNED THE BALL OVER.
HE SHOULD BE CONSIDERED, HE HAS
REALLY TAKEN CONTROL OF THAT.
>> HE IS A BALLER.
BEFORE WE GET UP OUT OF YOUR,
WHO DO YOU THINK WON THAT TRADE?
THE KINGS OR THE PACERS?
THE KINGS ARE PLAYING GOOD,
PACERS ARE ALSO PLAYING DECENT.
WHO WON THAT TRADE?
>> SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I THINK THAT'S SO FUN.
THE KINGS HAVEN'T BEEN RELEVANT
FOR A LONG TIME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT'S BEEN
SINCE THEY WON A PLAYOFF SERIES
OR MADE IT.
BUT I'M GOING TO SAY THE PACERS,
THEY HAVE A LOT OF GOOD TALENT
AND YOU KNOW YOU HAVE IT LOCKED
UP WITH HALLIBURTON.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY THE KINGS.
I THINK THEY ARE PLAYING WELL
NOW.
HOW DO YOU GUYS FEEL ABOUT
SACRAMENTO KINGS TO WIN IT ALL?
THAT'S WHY I LAUGHED.
I THOUGHT IT WAS SATIRE.
>> IT'S TOO EARLY TO SEE.
I'D SAY IT'S EVEN BUT IF I HAD
TO PICK HIM IT WOULD BE THE
PACERS.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
BOTH SEEM LIKE THEY ARE BALLING
WITH  THE RESULTS AFTER THE
TRADE.
EARLY ON IN THE SEASON, BOTH
GETTING OFF TO DECENT STARTS.
LET'S REVISIT THIS LATER IN THE
SEASON.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT AS THE
SEASON GOES ON.
BUT IT'S BEEN FUN.
WE'VE DONE A PARLAY, ALSO
TALKED FUTURES. THE PRODUCER
WANTS TO TALK GRADING PEOPLE'S
BETS.
BUT NO, WE ARE GETTING UP OUT
OF HERE.
IT'S TIME TO GO WIN SOME MONEY.
IT'S TIME TO GET THESE PEOPLE
TO GO BACK ON FANDUEL WITH US.
I'M GOING TO SIGN UP.
ONE LAST THING.
>> JUST HOPPED IN, HE ASKS, ARE
YOU GOING TO POST THE PARLAY ON
INSTA? WE WILL ABSOLUTELY POST
THIS EVERYWHERE AND WHEN WE CASH
, WE WILL POST IT AGAIN SO YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE IT IN JUST
A FEW MINUTES.
LET'S GO.
>> I GOT MY LUCKY T-SHIRT ON.
MY NAME IS GREG, NEXT TO ME IS
MICHAEL, AND NEXT TO HIM IS THE
MAN THAT CONNECTS US TO YOU.
PRODUCER RYAN.
WE ARE ABOUT TO GO GET RICH, WE
JUST PUT IN THE PARLAY THAT IS
LIKE +700.
I'M OUT, BOYS.